two mass killings in as many days in the
state of California police in Half Moon
Bay South of San Francisco say the
latest shootings happened in two
separate locations police were first
dispatched to a mushroom farm
upon arrival deputies located four
victims deceased with gunshot wounds
a fifth victim also suffering from a
gunshot wound was transported to
Stanford Medical Center with
life-threatening injuries
soon after officers found three more
people shot dead at a local trucking
company a San Mateo County elected
official said those killed were
agricultural workers of Chinese
ethnicity the suspected gunman went to a
police station apparently to give
himself up video shows officers bringing
him to the ground and putting him in
handcuffs police say they recovered a
semi-automatic weapon from his car his
motive is under investigation
investigation the suspect identified as
a 67 year old Half Moon Bay resident
at 4 40 p.m Zao was located in his
vehicle in the parking lot of the
sheriff's substation here in Half Moon
Bay
by a sheriff's deputy
Zao was taken into custody without
incident
local officials responded with shock and
outrage in the end there are simply too
many guns in this country
and there has to be a change this is not
an acceptable way for a modern society
to to live its in conduct its affairs
even as news of the latest mass shooting
came in mourners gathered in Monterey
Park near Los Angeles to remember the
people killed in a rampage at a ballroom
dancing Studio on Saturday night the
11th victim died in hospital on Monday
both the suspected gunman and the
victims in these mass shootings were of
Asian Heritage
the United States is the only country
where there are more civilian-owned guns
Than People Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los
Angeles